President Biden back from his five-day
taxpayer-funded Family Heritage Odyssey
in Ireland but he's not in any mood to
talk the old man snapping at reporters
who keep pestering him about his 2024
plans
whether the last few days has changed
your Calculus and when you make an
announcement on your plans no no no no
no I I've already made that calculus
we'll announce it relatively soon but uh
the trip here just reinforced my sense
of optimism about what can be done so
you've made a decision
I told you my plan is to run again
whoa sorry Gramps but the media is ready
to do Biden's dirty work on what's
taking so long the New York Times saying
quote closed door meetings about when to
rule out the president's campaign are
intensifying still with no serious
primary Challenge and Republicans
infighting he feels little pressure Dana
you're the political Mastermind here is
this that Rose that Rose Garden strategy
where they just stay out let the
Republicans fight it out
I knew my phrase yes um any time every
time the Press asks him about it and he
says I already told you I'm running his
staff is behind me going no hopefully no
not running not running yet and a couple
of things are happening so yes they want
Republicans to to be the invite to do
the infighting Biden would love for the
focus to be on Trump and just let it be
about Trump and then see if he can
figure out a way to get in the basement
again and go through with the next
election but something interesting
happened in the last month his poll
numbers have collapsed even they're even
worse than they were before and so
there's no real viable at this point
excuse me Marianne and Robert
um
competition for Biden right now if Trump
is the nominee Biden feels like yeah I
could do it right but what if he's not
so they also want to wait for another
reason because as soon as they announce
and they have to start adding in all of
these different
um Financial disclosure issues but the
other issue is the issue that they're
talking about right now with Dianne
Feinstein I'm not saying that Joe Biden
is at a point where Dianne Feinstein is
but everybody in the Democratic party
now is embroiled in a discussion of when
is it too old when are you too old to do
the job and it is a real discussion I
don't think that the Ireland trip was a
great one for the White House they I
know they'll disagree with me but I
think from as a viewer observing it it
was not great yeah and we think about it
when you put it that way you got you got
Biden Feinstein fetterman I mean that's
a that's that's not the Brain Trust well
you know he called the lid before 10.
could it be he who could it be 4 10 a.m
so do you think he ever actually came
back
oh he went to the beach oh did he oh he
went to the beach to the beach house wow
to the beach house whether or not you're
at the beach or you're home like
Feinstein you know we talk a lot about
these days uh artificial intelligence
when we talk about a future where we
have very little control I would suggest
you we might have the artificial
intelligence presidency which is it's on
autopilot who knows truly's in control
of our country it seems to be split up
between a committee of people and to
think that Joe Biden would run again at
the age of 82 at the end of his term
being 86 it's like we're fully going to
embrace a future where not sure who's
the leader not sure who's in control if
I might Greg I think this is fascinating
well there's this report out which you
may have Greg about the rise in
Independence over the last couple of
years 45 now they think largely
different by Gen X and and perhaps some
Millennials who don't identify as
Republican or Democrat I find that
really fascinating because we usually
think independent means interest I don't
think that's what it means and I I do
think that America First Donald Trump's
restructured Republican party did reveal
the appetite for a populist message with
some conservatism in there that really
is that is totally restructured the way
that we see politics and doesn't fit
cleanly anymore into Republican and
Democrat judge imagine I hate playing
this game because it's so cliched
imagine if Trump took his family on a
family vacation
would be pronounced well yeah can you
imagine him and his sister and his kids
and their kids and the grandkids at
least the one grandkid that he
recognizes Dana and uh you know with no
press conference no discussion with
anybody and you know it makes sense that
he said the trip reinforced his optimism
about running he was arrested so now he
can run uh but but I agree with what
will is saying I was stunned at the
percentage of Independents who literally
are outnumbering both Republicans and
Democrats I think people are fed up with
the parties I think they're fed up with
politics I think people see issues not
as a right or left but it's like real
issue inflation is a real issue can I
pay for food on the table crime is a
real issue I don't care if it's Alvin
bragger or or you know Rudy Giuliani
who's Prosecuting crime I want it to
stop and so you know what we've got is
Joe Biden who's alone you know car
driver in the Democrat Lane and you know
he's at the lowest number I think he's
ever been I think he's 40 right now
which is probably one of the lowest
numbers that Donald Trump had and it
doesn't mean anything people have
reached that number some have gotten
reelected and some have not two
presidents have gotten reelected from 40
and two presidents have not so this is
very it may look solid and secure for
Joe Biden I don't know if it is I think
this is a very different time and I know
what you're going to talk about in terms
of you know what you think about
abortion and that overall impact on the
election and to a certain extent I do
agree with you on that but at the same
time it's not about party it's there's
something else going on in the country
all right Jessica I think we don't need
to go to you now
honey I could have guessed that you were
going to say that in fact when the judge
I think oh she's being nice and then I'm
like oh I'm gonna lose my time
so yes I would mention that and we've
been talking about the rise of
Independence for years now but you're
right they're not centrists they all
have one or two issues that make it
impossible for them to vote for the
other side when things have gotten this
polarized if you go back a few decades
ago it wasn't the same way people had
more commonalities in terms of what the
platforms were you know talk about
limited government or bigger government
the tax brackets were even closer
together no one was talking about going
back to you know Eisenhower levels you
know people were just saying this is a
10 range let's say
um the abortion issue is Major it was
obviously major in the 2022 midterms
um something really interesting happened
this weekend a major GOP donor a
billionaire went to the New York Times
and he said that he is stopping all
campaign donations to Ron DeSantis that
him and his friends are extremely
concerned about his new six-week
heartbeat bill that he signed in that
private ceremony that he didn't want
anyone to see he also mentioned book
Banning which sends you know a stake
right through the heart of the argument
that the GOP is making that they are not
Banning books this is a guy who wants to
back you he wants to pay for your
campaigns and he sees what's going on in
the kind of alienation what books was he
talking about banning is this like you
know uh the color purple or is this
stuff that has like actual graphic sex
in it that children can see I love how
when the Democrats do that they go book
Banning but they don't say you could
probably still get those books by the
way anywhere anywhere you just can't
have a teacher use it for instruction
how is that banning I think the people
know what they feel about this issue
they know what they have heard from
their local politicians especially if
they're being misled I'm well first of
all I'm just I'm quoting a GOP donor
someone who I probably agree with on
next to nothing this isn't me this isn't
I'm quoting somebody who's saying
something's happening that he doesn't
know about
how about this elections have
consequences I've never heard that
before well I'm glad that I was able to
coin it right here on this episode of
The Five
to the point about the vacation quote
vacation so first of all I don't know if
you saw the scene in the County Mayo
rally where he came out to the Dropkick
Murphys and the castles lit up in the
back and people were ecstatic about it
so first of all expect Dropkick Murphys
to be a kind of Joe Biden walkout music
going forward it wasn't like this guy
was a nothing Burger up there that he
wasn't real well received that people
weren't happy to see him in Ireland okay
you act like he is a international
embarrassment and he is absolutely
nobody said that oh I will roll the tape
more of your time than I do no he didn't
stop one more thing if if the trumps had
gone on vacation excluding the fact that
Donald Trump has
a major germaphobia and owns enough real
estate that he can go to his own Resorts
I mean this is a guy who flies home
every night if he can because he wants
to sleep in his own bed which I
understand I think that's really nice my
dad used to be that way too but
obviously didn't own hotels it's
completely different to act like it's
some big deal that the guy went to
Ireland he did meet with elected
officials it isn't what yeah
so now you agree you just made a whole
stink about it so what you're saying is
every president from now on should be a
billionaire
or we should re-elect Trump because then
we don't have to pay for the trips
no I said none of that at all anyway
that was fun though I wanna Brian kill
Mead I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now